guys you know what renegade is saying
about you don't know what's going to
come out of a connection
and you guys you guys can believe this
one or but not believe it i'm irish i
know i run my mouth but
i had um i i as as you guys know a lot
of my business is done by socially
meeting people out and about in high-end
bars restaurants in washington dc
and i had a i had a pretty
well-connected girl come up to me once
and she said look i know this is like
two two or three years ago she goes you
know i know you're on your mountain
you're always having a nice glass of
whiskey in your hand but she said
did i hear you say that you knew the
queen of spain's sister
and i mean to anyone off the face that
that's like the biggest load of crap
you've ever heard in your life and i
said well i don't know her but i've been
out drinking with her i said why she
goes i need to get into this really
exclusive catholic school in spain i
said all right i'll make a call
guess what the girl sat on the board
three months later we had these two
connecting with each other and she got
into the school
and just back to renegade's point you
don't know how many degrees of
separation people are until you start
becoming a node and then you become a
force multiplier you know 10 more people
who know 10 more people and everyone is
again business game it's not called
is always a networking a game
opportunity right so it's like when
you're out and you know you go to the
coffee shop or you go to the library or
you go to the club right you're going to
talk to girls everywhere well same thing
you go off to dinner
talk to everyone at the restaurant i
have one restaurant that i go to that i
like the food and i thought it was
awesome so i just wound up you know
talking schmoozing and then winds up
they offered me an investment
opportunity i started looking at the
list and there's a lot of a-list
high-profile athletes celebrities and
everything that are already active
investors in this restaurant which i
would have no idea if i would just treat
it like oh okay i'm just going to a
restaurant i have a good time i eat my
food and i go and i leave it's like no
no that's a huge network opportunity so
you know follow whatever it is you're
looking for follow it are you looking
for for money and affluence go to some
affluent areas and restaurants right and
start networking there get to know the
people that work in that industry
because again let me just give you guys
a quick visual here on on like the
leveling up process like it like it kind
of goes like this
right like it's a stepping up sort of
process and it's like as your network
sort of improves like it's like the tide
raises the ship right so it's like a
step-by-step process of getting into
different rooms with different peoples
and different organizations like when i
started my very first business like
20 years ago practically now i didn't
have
um entrepreneurs accelerator program i
didn't have
entrepreneurs org i didn't have a
business coach
the very first thing that i got
introduced to was something called bni
which in hindsight sucks i don't know if
it's still around today do you guys know
bni it's something like business
networking something or another and it
was like all it did was it put me in a
room with
a dry waller a plumber a dental
hygienist
i don't know some nail salon chick and
like one or two other people from random
trades and it's like all they really did
was like hey this is what i did here's
my card if you know anybody that needs
this i'd love to
you know offer them a 10 discount or
something like that it was like okay
well that wasn't a great use of my time
but it was the starting point and then
one of the guys in that group i
kept in touch with we grabbed lunch and
it's like you know we had some
conversations and i learned about
this um
uh magazine in toronto called profit
magazine and every year they do a um
fastest growing companies list and
they're like you know the dude's telling
me he's like yeah your business is
growing really fast why don't you apply
to get on the list to see if they'll
give you the award right because if you
because if you get on the list and you
go to a gal event then you're in the
room with the other 50 or 200 people
depending on what the award was and now
you have an opportunity to network with
them it's like okay cool idea right so
from bni which was a crap experience
personally but led to a one-on-one
experience which then led to a apply for
this list then go to the gala get on the
award list win
meet 50 other people that's also where i
met my business coach and i hired him
and then you know like the things just
kept leveling up from there right so i
mean you just have to keep
you know throwing yourself into it and
putting yourself in environment and
places that give you an opportunity to
you know be in better and better rooms
by the way guys i dropped the join link
so if you have a question you want to
ask the panel tonight or me or whatever
it's pin to the top on youtube if you're
watching elsewhere let me just grab the
youtube link and i'll just drop it in
the general chat so it goes to
uh twitch twitter and facebook and all
that so just click that and head on over
to youtube it's pinned to the top um so
what you guys should do is um take a
look at take note of like rich cooper's
example right where if you are in a room
and you keep going to different rooms
and you don't like them
you can create your own room yeah right
and so you can host your own events
right you can create your own networking
opportunities hey i want to meet these
types of people or individuals all right
i'm gonna throw a host a different type
of meetup like i went to a bunch of
different car events and
a lot of them i didn't like because
there's a bunch of dudes just standing
around the parking lot saying oh my gosh
like my car is like so cool it's like
all right well we can always just stand
around our garage like all day but
i want to like go for a drive i want to
get some food i want to like you know
get the social juices flowing so i just
created my own social events and
basically ran my own car club for about
a good five years so my absolute best
friends to this day i've met just by
doing that and so you know again if
you're
not
happy or satisfied with what's currently
going on don't be afraid to go take that
risk because i'll give you this two key
tips if you ever want to like create
your own cult or anything like that you
want to get a good solid following
give people a vision and show them a
good time and i mean that's basically
like what's uh you know it's been done
with this group like with the guys that
well the miami trip right there was a
vision that hey we're all going to come
here we're going to get together we're
going to bring some value and they also
had a very phenomenal time and after
that everyone's bonded like brothers so
don't be afraid to formulate what that
vision is but also create your own space
and show people to get them
the other thing too is you want to
always under promise and over over
deliver whenever you set up something so
if you're like
you know i'm setting up this this dinner
like a mastermind event like a
mastermind dinner you know for example
you wouldn't want
to give away to okay so let me put it
this way um
it was about two months ago
if you guys follow me on instagram you
would have seen the post but i went for
a drive on a tuesday
and it just started in like a group chat
so i'm gonna whatsapp group chat with a
bunch of guys from like the super car
club in toronto and it's kind of like a
subgroup
and the guy goes
hey we're going to do a drive next
tuesday out to niagara on the lake um
we're leaving from this location at 9 00
a.m for the day and it was just
assumed by everybody in the group that
all we're going to do is we're going to
meet up conventionally
grab something to eat or our coffee and
then go and tear up the streets and
raise havoc grab some lunch at a winery
and then head back home
only what ended up happening was there
was two big surprises so the two guys
that organized it
um for the group totally
out of pocket just because it's
something that they wanted to do
um the first place that we stopped at
was a race track which we didn't know
that we were going to so so they so they
booked a racetrack privately for two
hours
if you guys watch on youtube there's a
um
uh
two guys from toronto i think it's
called the smoking tire they were they
were at the race track filming um some
car for like a youtube video that they
had to put out and they had to throw
them off the racetrack so that we could
get on the track and use it right so we
had it for two hours we did a bunch of
drag racing did some lapping i got some
video um i don't think i've actually
published a video yet but i got some
video that i'm put out at some point
probably during the winter and and then
we left from there and then we went to
the lunch spot and we go to the winery
it's like okay cool you know we figured
we'd just go to the restaurant no we had
a private gazebo at the back big
surprise you know with the chicoutery
boards and wine and you know the ladies
were bringing us drink we had like you
know private service and all that cool
cool awesome we're just sitting there
chopping it up shooting the [ __ ] i don't
know where these two guys with these
stripe yellow vests come out with like
headphones on with like you know mics
and all boom mics and that sort of thing
and they're like
all right guys so the helicopters are
going to be here in about 10 minutes so
we need to tell you you know what the
safety protocol is for we're like what
the [ __ ] helicopters like you kidding
like you guys organized helicopters for
us too so it's like all of a sudden now
these two helicopters land on the front
line of the winery we hop in we go over
the niagara falls you guys can go to my
stories
i think they're still there in the
archive thing but it's like
under promise and over deliver when you
get involved and network and this is how
high value men do things right it's like
hey we're going to do something cool and
then when everybody shows up they leave
at the end of the day oh and then on top
of that then we had an amazing dinner uh
private dinner at this restaurant it was
like it was it was like
i mean i would call it a michelin star
but it wasn't but it was phenomenal food
and then you know we had headed back
home at like nine o'clock at night and
that's how you want to do these things
right like you want to you want to
surprise people like shock and awe them
with
pure awesomeness basically is what it
boils down to if that makes sense anyway
so rich what you're saying is if i throw
an event at my place in january just say
hey come over for some hors d'oeuvres
and some beer we're just gonna hang out
shoot the crap but instead it'll be
middleton rare whiskey and someone might
kick ass cooking yeah absolutely no you
got to give us helicopter rides too
you know yeah that's only for comedies
a couple a couple of helicopters is like
off the charts sort of like you know
stuff that you don't expect but you know
it's like that's that's an extreme
example of under promise and overdove
because all we thought was is going to
be about a dozen guys and everybody was
totally [ __ ] shocked right there was
guys in a group that like found out
afterwards and they were kicking
themselves and dude i was telling them
like you need to structure your business
so that you can on a tuesday on any
given tuesday just not go to work and go
and drive your car with everybody else
but all these guys are like well don't
don't you have jobs and i got to be
there and i got to do it
okay fine fine have fun you know doing
your thing and then at the end of the
day they're like well we missed out on
the helicopter rides we missed out on
the dinner we missed out on the
racetrack it's like hey sucks to be you
guys
brian i i appreciate that pinot [ __ ]
reference
and also
rich it's a little it's a little hard to
top your story it's really awesome but i
feel like we've been talking a lot about
entrepreneurship and social networking
and i just want to share for your
audience who are working in the tech
industry
um
there are two things that i think it
helps a lot in getting a new job if you
work in the tech industry
um especially under a corporate
structure number one is you want to game
your recruiter
right so there's a lot of head hunting
company there's a lot of people that are
giving you cold calls on linkedin you
want to look for the ones that are in
the top recruiting companies like harnem
you know all these other companies i
won't advertise for them but you want to
look out for people who are fairly
senior and high ranking
and they will give you cold calls
over the course of my
15 or so career
in high tech these people are in there
for life and you can build a
relationship with them
and the benefit of that is you will
always get a first preview of whatever
cool job they have
that they are contracted with
so basically you're never going to be
out of a job you just have to go to the
interview you have first front seat
access but the way to do it is
you want to give them referrals from
your own friends i know if you start out
as a college graduate if you just got
your msc um you probably have a lot of
co-workers who are working let's say you
work in the back end you work with
python you work with tensorflow and
they're looking for mobile developers
android so you have a few friends you
hang out with in your social circle that
would work with react node.js or angular
you refer them
right
and the other thing is if you ever
become a hiring manager
you want to work with them first
and you're not even paying them out of
your own pocket your company is paying
for them and they take such a high
commission we're talking about 20 30
of the annual salary of the position
they're trying to fill so you're
actually
putting them on the front seat in terms
of getting somebody into your company
and you're building a social network
with someone else's money
right so i've done this numerous times
with you know major employees in these
companies and they love me they love me
and they come back to me like hey
charles i know you're working for this
company or you have your own company uh
but we would like you to have a look at
this
right
um huge hugely important in any job that
you're you're at right is being able to
write game it and network especially if
you're in a corporate structure or like
whatever you work at chick-fil-a right
you talk to some customers because guess
what like people that can help you out
and change the direction of your life
some of them like chick-fil-a and we'll
come in and get some chick-fil-a so well
it's it's especially valuable in head
hunter in tech industry i mean the the
competition for good candidates who are
competent who will pass the technical
you know coding exams life that's
actually pretty hardcore and there's big
money for that like and the other thing
i was going to say is be nice to your
former employees right so i've worked
with teams of 12 teams of 20 you know i
have these direct reports be nice to
them so the first thing i tell people
who i interview fresh
is
i work with software engineers i work
with data scientists and if a project
fails if they didn't deliver
i know they're not lazy
right because they picked a hard subject
to study in college
and they have committed themselves to a
very difficult art right so i know
they're not lazy it's always something
else as a hiring manager i need to find
out i don't make assumptions about oh
they're stupid or they're lazy or
whatever like you would with all these
other you know kinds of jobs chick-fil-a
you guys were talking about i don't make
those i go and find out and i'm very
nice to my employees
and they come back to me right i have i
think there's about 12 of my former
employees they went to google evil
empire and all that right and and
another five went to amazon i can get
referrals i don't want to work for those
companies like i don't care right i want
to work for me but
having these connections uh it's great i
i get to keep up with the latest
development the biggest trends that's
going on in the field right you know and
i also get connected through that but
and also if you go to my linkedin they
have raving reviews for charles you know
as a managing director as a cto right i
i know how to you know talk to people
and get my employees to become very very
productive because i don't just blame
them i mean when they fail it's me right
and i think about what i did wrong first
so so be nice to you if you ever are in
that position be really really nice to
them because that really pays off in the
long run
obviously yeah
i was just gonna quickly say on the
other side
because i got some guys waiting here to
ask some questions too yeah never if no
matter what job you're working at never
let a good boss go to waste a good boss
can teach you so much and can help you
out in so many innumerable ways so i
mean because we've all had like some bad
ones and we've all had some really good
ones never ever ever let a good boss go
go away yeah you know i think mine is
with me half the time that's that's a
really really good point that josh just
made there i mean like the last job last
corporate job that i had working for the
man i think i was 29 or 30.
um
it was it was here in toronto which was
equifax which then turned into cbcl and
was one of the largest agencies there's
probably about four or 500 people on the
books
and the president of that branch
um decided to put together this um
mentoring program
and
i got assigned to work with the
president
now i didn't even think to ask for
mentorship
but what i learned
being able to have an opportunity to sit
with the president of a company that has
four or 500 employees
um
multi-million dollar like worth hundreds
of million dollars a year in revenue i
can't remember what the total annual
sales was because it was because it was
tied into a u.s branch as well but you
know being able to sit with him and i
probably spent a good 10 or 12 hours
with him over over a number of weeks was
invaluable so if you have like a manager
vp a president and they don't offer a
mentorship program which not all of them
will but ask you know like why not say
hey look you know i love the company i
love the business
uh graham really fascinates me can i go
and you know be mentored by him like is
there something that i can do to maybe
like add some value to his day and and
like you know work under him for a
little bit just ask
you